j'écris de moins en moins ah oui tu
préfères
tu ressemble à Verlaine
[Musique]
je ressemble à Verlaine à cause de la
barbe et toi tu ressembles à Rimbaud
parce que tu es ravissant est-il vrai
que tu as commencé à voir quand tu étais
prof pour ne pas bégayer et c'est la
vérité car je bégayais
abominablement bien j'ai été professeur
de philosophie j'ai eu 30 élèves il y en
a 29 qui ont été reçus
après j'ai fait deux ans en Allemagne
et en me disant la philosophie c'est
géniale mais pourquoi est-ce que 29 gars
ont été reçus et ben ils ont été reçus
parce que sans perdre un an c'est comme
si il redoublait car je leur répétais
deux fois ce que j'avais à l'ordi
exactement à une des plus beaux aphoris
c'est on voit ensemble mais on est sous
tout seul explication
et bien on n'est pas sous avec quelqu'un
on est sous avec soi-même
et bien moi je
quant à moi je dirais
quand je vois je ne suis pas seul en
France que je vois double il y a
Gainsbourg
[Musique]
tu es 4
comme moi dans une glace je me vois 4
et ce pas fini ce soir je serai 8
de notre phrase de ce jeune homme
fringant je ne me regarde pas 40
pas avec une seringue avec une seringue
non mais avec une double seringue dans
un monde d'hiver ça va tout seul on peut
mettre aussi le bocal puis l'injection
oui c'est trop enfin si on veut pas
faire autrement s'il vous plaît pour
nous deux
que quand tu écris tu arrêtes de boire
mais au wagon c'est la vérité mais
j'écris de moins en moins ah oui
ça me trompe moins quand même
un truc marrant c'est un point comme un
tous les deux on aime les flics et
commissariats je suis allé 33 fois au
commissariat de police donc 33 mètres
avec les pinces toujours avec les
princes qu'il retire pour que je puisse
me moucher ou faire autre chose
exactement couler un bon soi-même mais
se faire couler par quelqu'un d'autre
c'est tout rose
on a un point commun
l'alcool
et bien une chose que je ne ferai jamais
c'est d'écrire dans aspect de la France
et River je l'ai fait j'ai écrit dans
l'humanité aussi ah oui
la gauche me croient droite la droite
nous croit de gauche jouer entre les
deux moi je porte à gauche mais plus bas
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu